-Our next guest is a very funn
comedian and actress you kno
from her viral videos
and "A Black Lady Sketch Show.
Her book, "She Memes Well,
is available June 15th.
Please welcome to the show
Quinta Brunson.
How are you, Quinta?
-Hey, Seth!
[ Laughs ]
-I'm so happy to have you here
Congrats on the book.
The title and the book itsel
is sort of about your entr
into show business,
which is based on the fact
that you did something
that became a very popular meme.
-Yes.
Yeah, I did a video.
It was a sketch, but peopl
thought that it was real
and it became
a very popular meme.
It was me saying, "He got money"
at a movie theater
to a man who bought me
some popcorn and Skittles, so.
[ Laughter ]
-For those who might not know,
here's the meme.
-Ooh!
-And I've certainly
seen it as well.
But how did you --
Because you mentioned
it was a sketch, you know,
and, obviously,
you wrote this sketch,
you performed the sketch.
You probably assumed that people
would engage with it as a sketch
and, yet, it becomes a meme.
And how did you find out
that it had taken off that way
-I found out when my friends
sent me the meme
to express
that I had become "famous"
and so I had money,
but that wasn't the case.
I was not any of those things.
But, yeah, I was shared it
at the time,
when Instagram wasn't even
a sharing platform.
It wasn't the digital sharin
platform that it is now.
It was just, you know,
someplace you could
post photos of yourself
and they had just gotten video
so I posted that,
just playing around,
and then it blew up.
-Yeah. So the meme people
never gave you a kickback
on how often
you were being used.
-No, no.
No control over that.
[ Laughter ]
-But you make the argument -
and I think
it's a very good one --
that memes,
maybe, are dismissed,
but are a very nuanced for
of communication.
-Yeah. Memes -- I compare them
to like hieroglyphics, kind of
They're these pictures
that we share,
that mean different things
to different people.
And, I mean,
one of my favorite memes i
this meme of Oprah
holding a can of beer
and like toasting it to someone.
I don't know the origin
of the photo,
but I use it for celebration
I actually used it in response
to a tweet about this show
I'm happy I'm going to be here
But memes are a form
of communication
that shouldn't be dismisse
because it's how an entire
culture of people communicate.
-Well, it's also, I think, it'
sort of a three-dimensional,
in many ways,
form of communication,
where, you know, you're gettin
more across when you do it
than you might do just
by typing out words.
-Yeah. Sometimes memes
just say what I can't.
It gives the emotion
that I need to give,
that too many words would kill
-[ Laughs ]
-Like now, I wish I could
just give a meme.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, they should put
a meme in in post,
if you want to tell us.
-Oh, thank you. Thank you.
-You talk a lot about your
family in this book
and I'm always fascinated.
When I'm reading it,
I want to know if the family
that I'm reading about
is reading it as well
and how they are taken
to this presentation that ha
been given to the world.
Has your family read the book?
-They have not.
They will not.
They're not allowed to.
I let them purchase it
because that helps you,
-[ Laughs ]
-you know, when they purchase.
-But no. Actually, no, I kind of
don't want them to read it
My parents don't like
when I curse.
It's a lot of cursing
in the book.
They don't like, you know,
sex, drugs.
I don't need them to read it
Honestly, I didn't tell them
about this show tonight, so...
[ Laughter ]
...let's keep that
on the down-low,
NBC promotion team.
-I will tell you,
no matter what I thought,
I feel like,
if I wrote about family,
some of them would get out
and buy it.
Now, you have you heard
from anyone
that they're going to do that?
-I just like told them
that, yes,
the book is "coming out,"
in theory,
I didn't tell them when or how
-Gotcha.
-You know what I'm saying?
-Yeah, so they have to do
some legwork, at this point,
if they want to get it, yeah
-If they want to get it,
you know,
but I keep them in the dar
about a lot of stuff.
My mom, one summer,
got obsessed with Issa Rae
just like the concept of her
But then, she was like, "I wan
to watch your show 'Insecure,'
and I was like, "Actually,
Mom, that got canceled.
[ Laughter ]
That's not airing."
So I just try to --
-Yeah, you did a favor.
I think you helped everybody
on that side
of the equation, there.
-Exactly.
[ Laughter ]
-You talk about how everyone
in your family
has very beautiful names,
yourself included.
Do you want to share with us how
your mom came up with Quinta
-Yes. So my mom came up with
the beautiful name of Quinta
by being too tired because I
came too late in her life
to think of anything else,
other than the number
of the child I am.
[ Laughter ]
I'm number five.
They found the name Quinta
in a book.
It just means "five."
My brothers and sisters
have like "prince of faith,"
"princess of Africa,"
and I'm just "five,"
but I kind of like it.
It gave me some freedom in life.
-It's really nice.
-I don't have anything
to live up to.
Thank you.
-And I think birth order's
really important
and you sort of present
to the world exactly,
on introduction, where you
landed, which is nice.
-You know.
And I get to make up
my own future.
That's the difference between me
and my brothers and sisters.
They have a lot to live up to.
I just have to be
the number five.
-You talk, in the book,
about how you did deep researc
of "SNL" cast members
and you mention many by name
each one a dear colleague
of mine.
A lot of overlap with me
and everybody you mentioned.
-Right.
-Nary, nary
a "Seth Meyers" in the book.
-Right.
-Yeah.
-See, so, Seth,
what had happened was...
[ Laughter ]
...so, so,
the thing was --
I should've kept the book
from you, too.
[ Laughter ]
No, but the thing was,
is that, you know,
I mentioned all of the perfo--
You were always
on "Weekend Update"
and it's not
that I didn't consider you
an inspiration or anything
I was just talking --
-Yeah, 'cause guess what.
I got money.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Sigh ]
I know, Seth.
Seth, I think you're --
you're doing alright.
You got a late night show.
You don't need a mention
in my little book.
-I mean, you listed,
I think, eight of them
and then wrote, "and more,
-[ Laughs ]
-so, that gave me
a ray of light. [ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
So, yeah.
You were there in spirit.
-Thank you.
I love people writing
about early jobs.
I think it's really helpfu
to people who want to brea
into this business
to understand exactly what
you have to say yes to.
You said yes to something
and then had a great amoun
of integrity
in saying no to it as well
-Yeah, you're talking
about the prank show?
-Yeah.
You know,
I knew it was a prank show
I just knew, which I think -
-So what happened?
You answered a Craigslist ad
-So I answered a Craigslist ad
when I was super broke.
And it just said
that we had to draw.
That was it, which,
I could draw.
I went to art school.
I was like, "I can do this."
It was like $25 or $50.
But I get there and there'
this man in a toga,
this toga
that we're all drawing,
but his toga starts to fall of
and it reveals
about a three-foot penis.
[ Laughter ]
So I'm just looking around
at everybody else, like,
"Nobody else is seeing this?
We're on a prank show.
No one else...?"
So, you know,
I just start clocking the room
I see the little spaces
where cameras can be.
Come on.
I've done this before.
I grew up watching
Jamie Kennedy.
I don't know
why everyone else didn't.
I knew we were on a prank show
So I tried to leave
and, you know, a producer
ran out after me
and said, "Hold on.
Please don't leave.
We need you.
This is a prank show."
I said, "Yeah, I know.
You guys aren't that good at it.
This isn't a good prank."
That's the main reason
I didn't want to be in it.
It was a bad prank. Like -
-Right.
-But, anyway, the producer
tried to offer me more money
She got it up to $1,000.
-Now, why did they want
to give you so much money?
-Because of my expressive face
[ Laughter ]
-So...
-So, in the end, like,
even though you knew
it was a prank,
your reaction to it
was just like money in the ban
for the people that were
-Priceless.
-cutting this together, right?
-Yeah. And, to this day,
if those producers are watching,
I feel bad.
I mean, they could've
maybe been the next
Borat or something
and I ruined it.
I'm really sorry about that.
-So this is really impressive.
You walked away.
You said yes to this gig
for 50 bucks,
they got it up to $1,000,
and it was not
up to your level of prank
-No.
-And you walked.
-Yes, I walked and I didn't want
my first, you know,
appearance in the world to b
"Girl grimacing
at six-foot penis."
I didn't, you know,
want that to be my legacy.
-Well, I think we're all lucky
that you made that choice
and I think
it was a very fine one.
And congratulations
so much on the book.
Congratulations
on everything else.
It's really been delightfu
talking to you.
-Thank you, Seth!
-"She Memes Well," right here,
is available June 15th.